vision médiocre d'évidentes maladresse
tout ça détonne avec l'image que l'on a
des requins prédateurs surdoué
c'est pourtant proche de la réalité la
plupart d'entre eux sont des
opportunistes qui attaques à
l'aveuglette et réussissent rarement du
premier coup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme tous les albatros synchronisent
leur départ il y as pendant quelques
heures des dizaines de portes unités à
saisir il suffit d'être là au bon moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la sélection naturelle fonctionne depuis
toujours selon le même principe stimuler
l'instinct de survie donner leur chance
aux plus résistants aux plus dégourdi